I'm Chuck divita our firm growth process
group helps early-to-mid stage
technology companies get investment
acquire customers and grow revenues and
profits all right we are not a sales
training company but I don't I'm not
offended Marcella I understand and
LinkedIn is a Lou LinkedIn probably
heard of LinkedIn I've found it about
three and a half years ago four years
ago LinkedIn is an online professional
tool based on people's professional
networks probably better run across it
one way or another so yeah we're about
three and a half years old we do a lot
of different things we do personal
professional services and we do
recruiting and we do sales sales support
lead generation and we serve almost nine
million people in the world great so my
background includes started life as an
engineer here in the valley
later after working as a product
marketing engineer and technology
companies I came to the business school
and got an MBA this June will be my 37th
anniversary I guess that's a good thing
and I've done two startups and sort of
migrated from larger companies down to
smaller those startups made it into the
mid 20 millions of dollars kind of range
in the old days when you started from
scratch kind of like the current days I
guess and then got some customers and
then got investment and I've done a
public turnaround our firm growth
process group has been around for 11
years helping technology companies
originally only in the enterprise
software space we've now expanded that
into several fields including appliances
instrumentation and interestingly enough
we have a partner now in the clean
energy space and we are holding a number
of events in energy technology and we've
had some successful assignments with
energy technology companies and that's
going to be a very exciting area so I
have been talking about acquiring first
customers and reference customers for
some time I teach in the continuing
studies program I teach three classes a
year in May on Saturday May 5th I'll
teach a class on salesmen
excellence all right a one-day workshop
and of course it used to be just about
enterprise because that's what was of
interest and as we've evolved now if you
look at where the VCS are investing
money you know they sort of say well
enterprise is dead I don't believe that
but also there's tremendous interest in
the consumer and so it's back to
eyeballs but we don't call it eyeballs
right because that was a bad thing so
now it's an advertising model and so as
I was crafting this material last fall
for a presentation that we did to a
group of entrepreneurs from Moscow Alan
joined as a panelist and then he and I
worked together to incorporate consumer
content because getting to consumers is
really important and I can't spell
retail so that's why we're sharing the
presentation I would encourage you to
ask questions throughout as opposed to
holding them to the end in the interest
of time I may have to cut them short but
let's make this be interactive let's
make it have value for you so some key
questions you might think about is what
problem are you solving for customers
notice the word technology is not there
right that probably isn't unusual for
business school people but it might be
for technical entrepreneurs what is your
value proposition in other words how do
you translate what you do into economic
or pleasure value as you'll hear from
Alan what do you want from your early
customers be very very clear about what
you're looking for from your first
customers okay and oftentimes I'm going
to suggest it it's not revenue that
doesn't mean you don't want to get money
from them it's just that that's not the
most important thing what type of
product do you have or service is it
enterprise or consumer and then how are
you going to distribute you know what
are the sales marketing and support
kinds of issues and how about channels
all right should you use channels early
or later can you achieve reference
ability through channels or not those
are some of the key questions so in
terms of technology you have if we're
going to enterprises sort of the old if
you will traditional sometimes called
heavyweight model where we install
software behind the firewall and the
customer has a
you'll support maintenance burden over
the course of the life of use of that
software there's an appliance model
which much more like a plug-and-play
where you wheel it in you plug it in and
it works in their environment with far
less support and then of course the
exciting one is software as a service
right and and so the suggestion I'm
going to make to you is think about the
problem you're solving for your customer
and think about these as alternatives
for delivering that solution to the
customer
these way you do it does not necessarily
define your business model your revenue
model or your pricing model we have done
projects where we've done enterprise
license like pricing for SAS models and
the reverse where it makes sense okay on
the consumer side the question is are
you a web 1.0 technology company or a
web 2.0 technology and we have an expert
in Allen to talk about that so I'm going
to spend some time on the enterprise now
and these are some comparisons of
various attributes of selling to
enterprises we have an on-premise
license behind the firewall an
on-premise appliance and then software
sold as a service so the sales expertise
and post sales support moves from higher
to lower and you'll hear the venture
capitalists talking about it doesn't
cost anything to sell in a SAS model not
true but it is a lot lower than a direct
sales heavy duty license model
installation and customization typically
an enterprise license might be high and
in as perfect SAS model would be zero
right plug-and-play installation
likewise moves from the the not
available for premise license down to
absolutely for SAS there are significant
data security issues there are IT
support issues and total cost of
ownership that's TCO and and so in the
on-premise license you have to include
the infrastructure you have to buy you
have to include the IT people you have
to use to support it right all that
stuff is a total cost of ownership so
when you're looking at your value
propositions I by the way I teach a
class in the fall on developing value
propositions and pricing models you must
use a total cost of ownership basis when
you're developing value propositions for
the customer it's not just what you
charge your customer and then cost of
goods sold cogs right
moves from you have no cogs in an
on-premise license to very significant
for ISP services in a SAS model and then
of course the other issue is the source
tree you might well have multiple source
trees in an enterprise license model and
in an ideal SAS model you would only
have one and that's a significant cost
saver if you can do that that's one of
the reasons investors are attracted to
that model so key questions again in the
enterprise yes go ahead ma'am I the
question is do I have handouts of these
no but I am going to email a copy of the
presentation given your permission I
forgot to ask you but I assume that's
okay too - it's here anyway Marcelo I
think and he will make that available ok
so are you prepared to go to market
really
right come on
some of you think it should be revenue
as your initial goal right and I'm going
to suggest to you that if you don't get
your references squared away properly
you'll plateau out at some point that
will be unsatisfactory be clear on what
you want from your early customers why
will they buy how much will they pay how
should the sales process evolve
do you know who to sell to we have a
process we call a map of value to pain
we map our value proposition to the pain
of title types different title types
care about different things so get clear
on who should be buying your product or
might have acute pain oftentimes
early-stage companies think their
challenges to convince customers that
they need some all right wrong challenge
in my view you know what mine
I let me do this so when you go through
that process the a has come out in
people for title types you didn't
identify you should be addressing and
perhaps some you're trying to address
there might be a waste of time
differentiate between your sponsor that
brings you in and who makes the decision
to buy and also take a look at things
like what should your pipeline be like
all right what's the ratio of leads to
sales and then how about channels and by
the way direct selling is that you
telephone selling is the channel web
selling is a channel all right so this
is a progression of a company the blue
line is meant to approximate cash flow
you move from a vision stage to a
strategy stage you then explore some
opportunities to apply your solution to
different markets and different problems
and sorry and then you go into execution
mode once you've found the sweet spot
right how many of you are trying to do
something for both consumers and
enterprise as startup companies nobody
somebody okay
you won't likely you won't succeed and
so you're going to have some tough
choices to make reasons being company
culture in a consumer model it's an
out-of-the-box kind of thing right with
minimal support in an enterprise model
heavy heavy support the customer expects
that so trying to do both in terms of
the kinds of people you hire the
experiences they have the structures you
setup make it very difficult for an
early-stage company to do both so I
would offer that as an opportunity for
you
so now initially your product right has
a particular value proposition in a
particular pricing model right don't
design a perfect product first rather do
a prototype get it out there to get
feedback from your initial customers
evolve it into the next generation and
so on so one of the things you might ask
was and who should sell what at which
stage as we're going through this
initially it's the founding team trying
to get
to understand basic needs all right and
then we call that the discovery phase
then it's the executive team if there's
a sales executive fine we offer interim
services as sales executives for
companies where it's a combination of
technology and services and you're
learning about the feature set that your
customers will want and the objective is
four to six significant customers so
that's the learning phase then you go
into the execution phase with a
professional sales team standardized
products and solutions and it's very
very transaction oriented and we're
trying to get tens and hundreds of
customers now do you know where you are
on this particular schema can you
identify the place of your company you
should be able to do that and and one of
the things we often see is companies
will hire the outstanding star from the
large company in the related space is a
transaction expert in one of these
phases all right and these people are
not learner's they're out there to do
deals they expect products to be mature
they expect demos to be done they
expects solutions to be great right
which is not the case when you're going
to early-stage customers so be cautious
of that and think about the the talent
and the experiences you need at the
stage that you are in and when we see
companies hire the people that do this
well in these two stages it's usually
six to nine months they quit or get
fired that costs the company that costs
the individual right so you don't want
to go through that okay so these are any
two dimensions that you care about your
ability to rewrite the code tomorrow and
your ability to support it in
Afghanistan for free for the next five
years or anything else that matters okay
the X is a customer requirement the
circle defines your set of resources at
that point in time to serve those
requirements all right and how many of
you experience this next customer
opportunity comes along and it's
somewhere else yeah
that's fairly common for early stage
companies right and what we want and the
question is should you go there or not
because by definition you can't do both
right you can't serve both at a point in
time and what you want to find is a
market like this where there's enough
opportunities to achieve a beachhead
anybody who hasn't read Jeffrey Moore's
crossing the chasm been around for about
20 years all right a very important book
I share with you another book that's
really good
written by Steve Blank who has done some
seminars with me who's a very successful
entrepreneur founder of Epiphany it's
called the four steps to the Epiphany he
teaches the Haas School in Berkeley and
a lot of what I'm talking to you about
Steve talks about very eloquently in
that book from a product marketing
perspective so the entrepreneurs dream
about going to market is I have an idea
I'm going to design a product I'm going
to set some goals I'm gonna hire a sales
team and we're gonna go sell it isn't
that kind of how we look at it all right
very straightforward very serial all
right well I'd like to share with you
what I think reality isn't getting
enterprise customers in an early stage
of course you have the high level
strategic stuff the vision the mission
and the goals you select some target
markets that you'd like to go to if you
propose at this point what we call value
hallucination because it's not validated
in the marketplace all right but it's an
important exercise to go through you
propose what your ideal customer looks
like and you select some target titles
to go to with this proposed solution now
then you look for ownership budget and
immunity trying to convince people they
need some you go to a prospect you say
you have acute pain no thank you very
much you have acute pain no thank you
very much you have a cute cane budget
and ownership about the problem yes I'm
gonna spend time selling to you I'm
gonna work with you because that's
efficient all right and so think of a
filtering mechanism to understand these
things as opposed to a teaching
mechanism small companies do not have
the resources to educate the market
makes sense right and yet we see
companies trying to do that all the time
now then having identified those target
titles in those target markets you
iterate the process by going out in the
field and talking to executives about
what they care for and how you measure
acute pain is they must have or are
willing to create budget
in the current year for your solution as
item 1 2 or 3 on their budget that's
acute pain anything else isn't right and
so the measurement is easy the
information is hard to get all right
companies prevent us from getting to
budget owners when we call them economic
buyers people who make decisions who can
make the decision to buy your solution
now then having then tested the markets
you're moving from assumptions to facts
be very critical of yourselves about
your assumptions versus facts facts come
from customers all right facts come from
the field assumptions come from within
your organization
oftentimes we go through exercises with
clients and we test for assumptions
versus facts and initially the answers
are we have facts about all these
problems we solved and then we start
drilling and a large number of them tend
to be assumptions which is good if you
know you don't have facts you can
identify that fact and go out and get
some right you can configure projects to
talk to customers and get facts and
that's really really important now then
having selected a market because most
early-stage companies cannot serve more
than one market all right you choose one
and you focus on it and now you go
acquire your development partner
customers or your reference customers
you refine your product you develop your
sales tools you refine your value
propositions and you develop your sales
process and then you hire a sales team
and now you go execute and sell
repeatedly make sense all right I find a
lot of early-stage entrepreneurs do not
have the patience for this for the
testing and learning phase right they
think that their baby's so beautiful
everybody should want one and all I have
to do is see it and I'll buy it
all right show them a demo it'll sell
all right we see that a lot okay am I
going too fast
okay I figured not this is a Business
School group right okay so another thing
we see is entrepreneurs think that well
they've got a board and some advisors
who gave them four contacts and that's
going to equal four orders right and we
call that a whistle funnel right every
deal whistles through to an order right
and the reality is that since you have
the
least credibility at an early stage and
companies are unwilling to do business
with unproven companies large companies
are unwilling to do business with
unproven small companies all right you
need the widest funnel the most
opportunities in your funnel at the
earliest stage later once you've proven
that your solution works and you start
to be referenceable your ratio from the
top to the bottom will improve 200 might
not be the right number for you it could
be a lot higher or lower but I guarantee
you it's much bigger than you thought it
might be all right and again I would
repeat the challenge is to filter for
acute pain in the people you're talking
to as opposed to educating them on why
they need some educating them on why
they need some is a long process with a
low close rate okay the other thing
that's important is you need a managed
sales process to manage this because the
numbers tend to get large and you want
to be able to measure what you're doing
we tried this with twenty prospects it
didn't work okay change we tried this
with twenty prospects okay change this
next one we tried work let's try to keep
doing that for a while till we find out
it doesn't work right so measurement and
adaptation on a real-time basis is very
very important this is an eye chart I'm
not going to tell you about all of it it
merely says that to get the number of
orders that we want which in this case
is 17 customers in the year right with
an average deal size of $100,000 we have
to touch 4,800 prospects that makes the
point about the pipeline okay it's it's
a big number set and you should have a
model like this that looks at how many
prospects you need to touch to get to
the number of customers that you have as
a goal in your first year okay so let's
talk about a sales process some of you
have seen this in your prior lives
working with salespeople where there's a
suspect there's a prospect we do a first
call we do a demo we do a second call we
do a demo we do a third call we educate
them right
and more calls more demos been there
done this alright that question is is
there a pilot or a trial do we get paid
for it or not we wait for the budget
cycle and by the tenth call maybe we
find out do they care from a budget
perspective right we see this a lot let
me give you a little better process all
right
suspect prospect first call is qualify
and do a demo present your value
proposition broker for access to the
economic buyer the economic buyer is
that person who in turn F of their own
right can make the yes and no decision
they take input from committees but they
have the power if you want to read more
about different characteristics of
different buyers Miller Heiman strategic
selling defines it fairly well alright
by the second call you meet the economic
buyer you qualify that person's pain
urgency and budget now what do you do if
in the first call you don't get access
to the economic buyer see thank you very
much walk down the street to the
prospect who will give you access to the
economic buyer that is how you make your
selling costs go down per unit of
revenue dollar okay and by the third
call you negotiate the process and you
gain commitment to stop now if you have
a robust popular type line a lot of
prospects in your pipeline it's easy to
walk from deals that are not ideal right
so often we see companies without a
robust pipeline and so we hang on
to bad deals that is a natural human
reaction but it's very costly okay so
the robust pipeline is really really
important for early-stage companies
let's talk about ideal customer
characteristics this is a set the only
one that matters to you is the last one
willing and able to pay you should have
your own set of ideal customer
characteristics you should start homing
in on that I'm a big believer in
one-page list they're very powerful for
focus they're very powerful for
communicating to others on your team
even if you have a small team sometimes
or often we'll see
disagreement as to what's an ideal
customer so you need to work towards
consensus on issues like this all right
so what do you want from your early
customers you want time you want them to
review your specifications you want them
to look at your product
give you feedback come to meetings or
you go meet them right you basically are
looking for help now you do ask for
money because a free trial is not a
customer how many of you have customers
that didn't pay you somebody in the room
yeah that's a free trial sorry and
there's value in that but it's not a
customer value it's not validation of
what you're trying to do it's okay we'll
kick the tires kind of thing all right
maybe and so it's not about building a
revenue growth plan though that's not
the reason you're asking for money from
your first customers you're asking for
money from your first customers because
if you don't get money you won't get the
time make sense right if I come to you
and I say I'm gonna let you work on my
software product and I'm not gonna touch
any money and I need these three
people's time to evaluate and Alan comes
to you with his product different
application and now you give that Alan's
fifty a hundred thousand dollars needs
the same three people's time what's your
decision goes to Alan's solution all
right that's what I mean you need you
see you need to get the money to get the
commitment okay so here's a chart that
speaks to customers who buy early and
those who buy later these are the ones
who are subject to those transaction
salespeople right and notice in each
case the attribute is different early
adopters do not expect your product or
solution to be fully defined they don't
expect your value propositions to be
verified they're willing to go with
value hallucination and put their data
in so they can understand right
and they also generally tend to be
visionary as opposed to non visionary in
enterprises all right and they don't
expect the sales tools to be perfect and
the references to be perfect either so
that's another chart you need to think
about as you're crafting your early
sales processes so what about
approaching your first customer well
referrals a key from your board your
advisors your investors but brokered
contacts are what we call those they
don't equal orders the fact that you
were given a contact or maybe even given
a meeting doesn't mean you're going to
get an order you still needs analysis of
requirements on the customer side you
have to make sure that the strategic
decision makers are aligned with what
you're trying
to do and then you go in and you say
well so how do you do it now well we
have spreadsheets and we have this
database and it's all scattered and it
takes a lot of time and we catch planes
to do it well what if you could have it
all available to you
aggregating and assimilated in a fashion
that it was usable real time by all
people all around the world would you
buy it oh yeah I do that save us a lot
of money and prove our productivity cool
are you willing to participate in the
development because we have this core
technology but the products fully
developed all right if the answer's no
then what your action is say thank you
very much come back later when you have
a fully developed solution if the answer
is yes your next question is will you
contribute significant money now
significant money in my view is no less
than half of what you expect to charge
when the product is fully developed so
if your solution is $100,000 solution
charging five thousand dollars is not
significant money it doesn't represent a
significant enough commitment to the
kind of thing you're trying to do what
about the ingredients of the deal you
guys aren't asking many questions come
on okay so you want their time and this
means specific people right you what
about limited right to use or unlimited
right to use how many of you are faced
with that early customer says we want a
what sometimes called a site license
right to use throughout the corporation
or unlimited right to use I would
suggest to you that the only time you
want to give a truly unlimited right to
use all products all time all locations
all all of your company is when you're
out of air and what's air to a company
it's cash so if you're out of cash you
have no other way to generate it fine go
do one of those deals but the decision
that you are making is a trade-off
between the cash now and the customer
relationship later because when you do a
truly unlimited right to use deal and
later on you're successful you have a
sales force sales person looks at their
sales comp plans says I get paid on
generating revenue or bookings or both
no bookings or revenue coming from that
company they got it all nobody calls on
the relationship between the companies
degrades and the competition gets the
next opportunity at that company all
right so the only time you want to think
about doing that is when you're
desperate for cash in my opinion and it
matters a lot if you're successful in
the rest of
it doesn't matter okay you do want cash
how about a press release should you
negotiate the terms and the language of
the press release in your deal
absolutely why because your power is the
greatest just before their executive
signs the deal that's when you have the
most power to ask for stuff that you
want all right after you've signed the
deal if you don't have the press release
written into the deal what happens is
the PR department the corporate PR
department comes along and what's their
job their job is to prevent you from
releasing anything in terms of
information about what they're doing and
they have no ownership of the acute pain
for the problem that you're solving
right and so if you wait for PR after
the contract you're hurting yourself in
terms of what you could get out of it
okay investor interviews some number of
investor interviews per unit time with
specific individuals in the organization
likewise it the editor and analyst
interviews should be negotiated and then
what about stock I did a deal for a
company a few years ago with Hewlett
Packard's LaserJet division in Boise at
the time it was a hosted SAS deal about
$200,000 a year and so right towards the
end we were introduced to a department
called corporate development towards the
end of negotiations and they said so
we're gonna be your first customer we're
gonna get 5% of your stock right gulp
you know what do we do we really want
hewlett-packard we really don't want to
give up a 5% of our stock how do we deal
with that right and the thing I would
suggest to you here if you get hit with
something like that is bring in somebody
who is really skilled at negotiations
with large companies and who can use the
excuse of I've gotta go check you as the
founder of your company have a difficult
time using the excuse when you're in a
negotiation I've I've got to go check
because you you own the power to make
the decisions right whereas I on many
times have had titles that are not CEO
where I didn't even need to use it but I
wanted to go regroup myself to figure
out a new strategy
cheese and negotiation I'd say I
got to go check it's not an ego deal
it's a negotiation strategy so that's
another thing you want to think about
and then what about closing the deal
well dealing with as equals is really
really important right are you gonna do
a win-win deal or a win-lose deal when
loose deal means we won the order and
everybody else in your company support
right engineering says how we can do
this okay this doesn't fit with what we
do right and and so there's a lot of
broken glass around deals like that
win-win deal says we won the order and
it fits right in with what where we're
going as a company what we plan to
supply in the way the solutions we're
providing don't let the lawyers mess it
up I like to have a one-pager that's the
business deal that you negotiate and
then you hand it to the lawyers and say
give me this back in appropriate legal
language I'm not speaking badly about
lawyers I have a daughter who is a
lawyer who's in a high corporate
position and beware of people like
corporate development and use your
champions use the power this is one of
the reasons in enterprise deals you want
to have champions with political power
because there are going to be some
obstacles you're going to want them to
overcome for you as you're moving
forward so there is a trade-off between
the power of those in the line of
business and those in other activities
and that's one reason why I am NOT a fan
of starting low in the organization and
it'll automatically bubble up and yet
some people have successful operations
that way but the chances of you becoming
shelfware because your sponsors don't
have enough power to see it through the
organization is higher so the next most
important things get them referenceable
and for this in enterprises normally
services are key I deal with an affair
number of companies particularly those
from Israel interesting enough who say
well we're a product only company we're
not going to do services yes you are on
the front end you might later hand them
off to a services organization as an SI
but early on the SI is not interested in
working with you why you're not a proven
provider of value for them right and so
you have to provide the services early
on to make your solution successful to
the customer and would you like to have
somebody
else would you delegate to some other
company your success with your early
customers I don't think so
right and then modify your value
propositions as soon as possible so that
particular deal I told you about with
Hewlett Packard we thought that our
value proposition was about integrating
a disparate supply chain right and so
three months after I did the deal I went
back to him and I said so how are we
doing on integrating your supply chain
and they giggled and they said we
haven't gone out to the supply chain
with this we love it but it's about
income turn internal control this year
and we'll get to the supply chain next
year so what do you think I said when I
went to IBM huh so you can't smart
people around a table can't come up with
those subtleties right you have to get
that from customers okay this is about
references no which kind of references
you want the first kind is those who
will say we will buy it if they have it
their only important for investors the
second kind say we've evaluated it we've
bought it but it's not yet an
operational use and the third kind which
are the best take the longest to develop
right it's mission critical we can't do
without it so when you're looking for
references know what stage you're at and
the particular type of reference you're
looking for I'm going to move through
this material
why executives the majority buy it's
about curing an acute pain and they are
investors right they're going to give
you some money now and expect to pay
back soon understand the payback that
they require this is a value pyramid
right and up at the top it's a sari down
at the bottom you are our vendor you're
a semiconductor manufacturer you're a
software utility tool right and it's
price delivering quality often times
hard to differentiate yourself from
others right the market is the largest
they're up at the top you know more
about the problem you're solving for
your customer than your customer all
right and I so it's about domain
expertise as you move up to the top in
software solutions it often means you're
going to go to a vertical right
orientation not always but it often
means that and if you're going to be
vertical as an early-stage company how
many verticals can you do one thank you
very much all right
a one and only one why being vertical
means you have domain expertise in your
company in your employees about the
problem you're solving for that
particular vertical you cannot assemble
for more than one as an early stage so
the important thing is to know where you
are know where you want to be and if
you're not where you want to be you will
need to change the way you do things in
terms of your configuration of product
and services and technology your
orientation to solving the customers
problem down here the responsibility for
the solution and the responsibility for
making it work is usually the customers
up at the top the responsibility for the
selection of the solution and the
responsibility for making it work is
usually the suppliers you will do things
dramatically different depending upon
where you are this is also a reason why
it's very very difficult as an
early-stage company to offer something
for five hundred dollars and something
for five hundred thousand dollars just
can't do it right okay value proposition
talks about revenue cost or control
improvement it answers these kinds of
questions and simplicity is really
really key here's a solution where
beforehand we're gathering information
we're aggregating it and then we're able
to take action we bring in our solution
and now we have much more time available
to take action call it selling or
whatever you want all right I would urge
you to create simple graphical
depictions of what you do for your
customers to the extent you can make
them this simple right you will have a
much easier time the amount of time that
goes into creating a very simple diagram
of what you do for your customers is
often huge don't be surprised if it
takes a hundred man hours all right it's
very very difficult alright and I can
tell you stories about the development
of these kinds of diagrams
here's that value proposition matrix
will reevaluate what we do we find out
how credible we look at where we have
customer facts and where we have
assumptions be objectively critical of
your facts versus your assumptions okay
this is an eye chart
it's our value pain matrix up at the top
we have title types IT finance
procurement so on down here we have the
problems that we solve and what we look
for is a combination of budget ownership
and acute pain in one sell isn't selling
across departments hard to do right it's
much harder to do when you
credibility is an early company so you
want to find those pockets of value
proposition and title type where you
have budget ownership and acute pain all
in one cell and then you focus there
right that's what you do okay different
titles care about different values so so
the messages are derived from your value
proposition sorry I'm rushing but I
don't feel like I want to move ahead
when it comes to ROI and payback
understand the customers costs in an
enterprise solution training
implementation infrastructure and then
they start to see some benefit as your
solution is adopted and we used to talk
about payback
what's much more important about ROI
what's much more important is the time
to cross through zero and typically for
enterprise type solution in today's
economy that's six months for the energy
market that's about two years so for
different markets it's different
understand what your target markets
criteria are for payback how can you
know your pricing if you haven't
established your value and you haven't
figured out the payback that your
customer set once so it's really really
important to go to value and understand
payback requirements to set pricing okay
so here is a perpetual license versus a
subscription license from a customer
view right and here it sorry and so we
have the license like I showed you in
the subscription model comes in with
lower cost and goes like this right from
a supplier view however we get a license
sell it for a certain sum of cash and
then we get maintenance and from a
subscription model it starts out a lot
less cash the implications for
investment are very very important and
it goes through any the ideal model is
you'd sell a perpetual license to start
and then transition them to a
subscription model when you hit the
crossover point and some companies are
doing that okay okay
Allen you're on pull down and advance
the slide push up to that okay
all right so I'm gonna change gears
pretty much completely so a lot of what
Chuck has said so far is true about
Lincoln's own sales efforts LinkedIn as
you know as a our revenue model is
basically built on a very large
collection of professionals and
interesting information about them and
the ability to sell access for
recruiting for sales etc to other people
via subscriptions which will allow us in
C to monetize that asset which has been
created by our users so we have a fairly
traditional sales cycle for the people
who are actually selling those business
products but what I primarily what I
will talk about today is how did
LinkedIn go about acquiring our
customers that nine million users who
are getting daily value out of LinkedIn
not all of them obviously but then
you're getting daily value out of using
LinkedIn to support their own personal
professional lives because I think in a
lot of ways there are lessons here for
anybody who's trying to start up a
consumer business sort of under the web
2.0 structure I warn you though that
unlike talking about sales and talking
about enterprise sales which has a
tremendous amount of study and
understanding behind it
consumer internet products in the web
2.0 world is an emerging science at best
so hopefully this will be useful and
interesting information but it's
probably not alright so so web 1.0
versus 2.0 I want to talk about this
very briefly web 1.0 as you all know
people are familiar with the traditional
web 1.0 businesses content sites web
directory stores Amazon I mean Fame
there's a famous collection of them
obviously from 1995 2001 a lot of ways
they were very traditional companies
with very traditional ideas how you get
to consumers web 2.0 has a very
different way of approaching it and when
I think about web 2.0 what I mainly
think about is take the lessons which
were learned from the first generation
and apply it to the second generation so
when you look at web 2.0 you look at
social networks photo sharing blogging
the distribution created by users and by
search engine optimization and the users
are actually the pub both the publishers
and the consumers of the content which
is being created the reason web 2.0
exists in the first place is that
basically web 1.0 is a very expensive
way to do business content production
and distribution operations all very
heavy costs however under web 2.0 we
managed to say let's look the back at
the companies that made it work between
1995 and 2001 take some of those ideas
so when you look at people who are
allowing consumers to create the content
the consumers to do distribution whether
you look at PayPal or eBay where
basically you do through viral spread if
there are other distribution forms you
can actually reduce your cost of
customer acquisition to zero or near
zero and I'm happy to say for LinkedIn
our cost of customer acquisition is we
even have a good measure of it because
we really spent about $30,000 on
marketing to the entire four years and
and the start-up time and the cost of
starting up is extraordinarily low for
web 2.0 just a much better way of making
it happen the key understanding though
and the one which comes to how you pick
those first customers is that in a web
2.0 company the users do most of the
work okay they distribute the product
they create the brand they communicate
it and they build the ass at the gym
that generates the revenue now in
LinkedIn skates like I said though what
you're building is a corpus of
professionals who then become a valuable
asset not only for themselves but also
for other users who are also included in
the group the bottom line to making any
web 2.0 product work and you can point
to YouTube or you can point to you can
point to some of those I'm Genie or Yelp
or Friendster and myspace is
participation
if you can drive participation then you
can build a valuable asset
so borrowing from chuck scrap if your
cash flow is going to look like that
then somehow you need would be building
value in the system and as they raise
that value you're able essentially to
monetize it
people monetize it in a lot of different
ways but basically you're basing all of
that either off a corpus of content
which has been created a collection of
users who have become part of the system
and are the resource that people want to
pay to get access to that VAT it's
adding a little bit to it that value is
created in this by this green curve or
participation if you can jumpstart that
participation curve correctly then
basically you're gonna be able to get
your asset off to a really good start so
we've seen a tremendous number of
companies go out there and be able to
get a good example I'm gonna talk about
a little bit here is Jeannie anybody
familiar with Jeannie it's a brand new
startup - about two weeks old or two
weeks since their public launch anyway
and they have I'm gonna guess I'm gonna
say 50 or 60 thousand people who've
already come and built family trees on
the system that distribution was
entirely done through blogs that's a
great start for a company like that to
get people involved because that
participation is gonna be building the
value of the asset which every
successive generation of use is going to
build up we're talking specifically
about some of them Yelp Yelp it sparked
social network part reviewing system its
distribution is primarily through people
inviting although that's actually
secondary it's primarily through SEO in
and placement of the various reviews
that are written about restaurants and
whatever and distribution through the
action through through placement in
Google or placement in Yahoo so I create
the reviews I get the reviews out in
front of people they come to Yelp and
consume
content also is a social network aspect
and sort of could get connected to
friends and bring them in to share your
reviews the value proposition that Yelp
is creating essentially these are just
examples it's only valuable if you're
able to create that mass of content that
mass of content is then what the next
generation has to build on top of their
revenue is based on people coming and
reading those and then seeing you see
sponsored reviews you'll see advertising
along the side so basically what they're
doing is they're monetizing that asset
but they built a product which causes
the causes the asset to grow in the
first place
Jeannie there's not a lot to say about
it we haven't always seen is good
operation basically at I know if Emily's
familiar with the way it works you
create a create a family tree for
yourself and you enter the email
addresses of people who are in your
family tree
they get invited and then they come add
information it's a very smoothy easy to
use interface it's a lot of fun it also
grows very quickly that tree is going to
become the source of value for every new
customer who comes in the door as well
as for genius of business although how
they're gonna monetize it I don't know
now LinkedIn LinkedIn has grown entirely
organically from the invitations the
eight founders sent in the sense of the
summer of 2003 up to the nine million
members we have today it grows through
invitations which go out to business
colleagues it's based off of your
outlook contact your webmail contacts or
whatever basically that is the asset so
it's not actually building content
although content is obviously part of it
profiles and so forth but learn to
create a large base of professionals as
the asset which we would then be able in
turn to you for those people to make use
of but also for the for our customers so
how do users create value this is where
it gets a little experimental
participation businesses rely on
internal cycles of customer behavior
okay so in curate poops jump before
again okay so basically although I can't
gesture dramatically but a very typical
one and one you're all familiar with
from
from watching viral businesses grow over
the years a very simple social network
viral cycle person a person who's in the
system invites somebody somebody
receives at some rate they visit the
site at some rate they join at some rate
they intern invited some rate inside all
of these businesses are cycles which
work like this little engines which
drive growth or drive content creation
ideally you would be able to identify
those things as you're creating your
business and say well this is the engine
that we actually want to drive if you
can't identify them you probably have a
problem you can't distribute it unless
you've got an engine which allows you to
move forward so as I said earlier the
important thing is that as you're adding
generations as you go forward each one
relies on the value which was created
before them relies on a critical mass of
value so you look at the way LinkedIn
group basically we got our initial group
of early adopters who came in and did
stuff and I'm gonna talk about that
specifically in a minute when those
people had reached a certain density in
a particular area essentially the next
group the next slightly harder to reach
group was able to see value in what they
saw on the website until that point that
group would never have become part of
LinkedIn because basically they looked
at and say well there's nobody here what
do you do with it
I can't even search for anybody I can't
find anybody I know I can't find anybody
I need every generation though has added
extra value to that and the next
generation comes in and says oh look now
I can do something with it and now
understand the value and it's been
interesting for us to watch as we go
along I see lots of people say oh now I
get it even though they joined three
years ago they still didn't know what
the hell is going on now they come back
and they say wow there's millions of
people here and half people I went to
school with they're here so now I can
get connected to them or I didn't know
you could do a reference search on
lengthy and that's amazing because now
there's actual value in trading and
actually without actual value created
engines at LinkedIn I'm gonna cover this
briefly what kind of engines actually
drove this drove that drove the
construction of LinkedIn the asset that
we've got the value propositions we put
in front of people
our professional identity don't lose
touch and use your network to get stuff
done okay
professional identity come expresses
itself as profiles when somebody
produces a profile not only are they
producing information which allows them
to get connected more easily allows them
to establish their professional network
but also makes them part of the search
that everybody else does by not losing
touch by keeping in touch with people
who are don't want to lose track of I
create connections and those connections
not only they spread the service but
they also create a denser network which
increases anybody else's visibility
around it so essentially every action
has a second action built into it which
says here's how it's going to add value
to the overall asset and obviously use
your network whether it's search or
services or new Answers project or
whatever every single one of those in
turn activates all the people in the
system so they come back and take
greater action if it's something we
discover as we went along instead
actions taken in the system caused
reactions among the people who they
affect and then those people come back
and act quick note about this there's
there are two different least two types
of value to be created one type is
content value the other is sort of
people or court or directory value for
companies like Yelp and Digg you need to
build some value in your it needs to
build some value in the corpus and the
actual content which is being created
before you actually consider
distribution because that corpus is
actually the thing which does the
distribution as I said earlier with
LinkedIn or any social network I think
what you're looking for more is
distribution first because in other
words distribution is the source of the
value if you have a broad distribution
you have broad value and then that and
that turns around it becomes the
valuable resource there they're
different but important because it does
in the end affect what customer
you choose to go out and and bring in on
day one depending on what your real goal
is that group that first customer
participation that bump of participation
you get at the beginning is absolutely
key to making making a successful fast
start one of the things which is almost
always true especially about new web
companies that are being created today
is that they almost always need to have
a fast start they don't get a fast start
and they're going to run out of money
before they're able to prove their value
proposition so what will that first
gender and first generation do it's got
to somehow start the engines that you
understand are gonna be part of you
system part of your part of your product
you've either got to build that critical
mass of initial value by writing reviews
on Yelp or they've got to establish that
critical mass of people by distributing
and that's the way LinkedIn did in the
beginning of LinkedIn we had very long
could argue we still have rudimentary
search features but at the beginning we
had very rudimentary search features and
the reason was there was no point it's
like yeah she did a little bit of
information so you could browse and see
things but the key part was distribution
and the distribution came based on
personal relationships not based on the
content of a quality of the things when
you get there and it's not that we
didn't think there was qualities that we
knew we couldn't prove it
until there was a very large number of
people there when we when linton went
out to acquire our first customers we
had in mind a very specific set of
people who we wanted to transmit our
brand we wanted to transmit essentially
a proper way of using the system we
wanted to represent the level of
seniority and elite miss that we believe
this if that's a word that we wanted to
have in the system
okay so we've hand-picked those people
and those first hundred first eight
people who did the inviting we focused
on that group but we also knew that
every single product has an early
adopter of market whether you want it to
or not okay that includes people who are
very interested in professional
networking they're interested in meeting
as many people as possible very
interested in sort of online
professional communities we knew those
people existed as well so our job when
we first started LinkedIn was build a
product
which is designed for the elite group
who we want to kick off our product with
then there's vice-presidents influential
people venture capitalists all the
people who were gonna drive that initial
growth that mattered so much to us and
that initial brand that mattered so much
to us but design a product which works
for everybody else but blocks the
negative behaviors that those people
might bring with them okay so if anybody
remembers there was no direct contact
available in LinkedIn when we started
the reason was that we were counting on
every individual back as a filter for a
bad action so basically I have to go
through you because you and I are
connected and I wanted to get to him
well if I'm a bad actor you can stop me
okay once we got to the point where
LinkedIn and established its brand
established adduce we were able to say
okay now by putting other mechanisms in
place were able to all actually allow
direct contact because we've established
our brand we established how people use
the system so when we acquired the to
answer your question
those people were acquired because they
heard about us they've read about us in
a blog they saw some press about us
whatever it is they came into the system
invited like crazy tried to tear up the
place not because not because they were
bad or evil but because that's how they
wanted to use the product but the
product was ready for them when they got
there so on day one we launched with the
ability to join cold talking about that
order that initial audience that people
who are going to come use the system
whether you want them to or not this in
the consumer internet world is a graph
that everybody understands because
basically you've got sort of one percent
of people who do 80% of the work ninety
percent ninety percent of people who do
the remaining twenty percent and then
everybody else hangs out and does things
occasionally okay the people you get the
people you need to make sure you design
for the people who are the top two
components of this pyramid there's a
question of overlap how much does the
desired audience that you want to go out
to overlap with that early adopter
audience because if you look at a
company if you look it up if you look at
say YouTube or you
look at Jeannie even or MySpace
there's a high level of overlap between
these two groups it looks something like
then like LinkedIn there's less overlap
in other words there really are people
out there who you don't want to be part
of that first audience
I'm sure this is all self-evident right
oh ok so and you'll get all this so
sorry I just try to get it all done
before we go and come back your question
isn't it so value proposition being key
things value revision for web people I
know companies and this is a problem
LinkedIn has still has simplicity
because users need to be able to convey
that value proposition generally
speaking a value proposition which is
back to pleasure and not the pain is be
much more successful no that's generally
true in consumer brands but it's
especially true here because for the
most part I'm most I'm I'm more likely
to participate if I'm doing something
which is fun then if I'm doing something
which is necessary ok
and finally surprise and delight if I
find something which is surprising or
anything and you guys if you haven't
looked at genie if you look at genie you
need is a great example of surprise and
delight and simply use interface and so
forth it's really excellent and
basically that's something I want to
share with other people just because
it's so cool and that makes a big
difference I wanted to raise the the
possibility of a hybrid model and one of
the things that I'm experiencing now is
some early stage companies are looking
at how they would go to market by first
attracting individual users or focusing
on an enterprise application and then
coming back to the other and what I'm
seeing investors vote for is attract the
individual users first the early revenue
being advertising and develop Enterprise
models later and so it is applying many
of the things that you talked about in
web 2.0 to a potential enterprise model
where you're getting sort of
professional participation first and
that's a little bit of a surprise but I
want to say that that's certainly an
opportunity all at that point once just
one second there are there examples out
there like salesforce.com and people are
familiar with Salesforce it's doing a
good job of essentially doing at a price
sales on an individual basis so they're
very interesting to look at disclaimer
of partner thank you very much for your
time and attention